the traditional life path of a female is
she's 17 she's 18 she's 19 and her value
is massively inflated and I don't blame
her of course this mass is being played
imagine being 19 years old have achieved
exactly [ __ ] zero in your life
knowing nothing you put makeup on and
and sports stars billionaires actors the
most important famous people on the
planet the richest man on the planet are
begging for your attention the ego
you're going to develop let's all be
honest right the ego your developers can
be mon you [ __ ] mental I'm special
I'm so gorgeous all this [ __ ] right
and then what happens as they grow older
as new generations come along because
the truth is most women are are at their
Peak attraction let's say in their early
20s as they grow older what they what
women become is far more fearful of
competition this is why you'll see a
woman who's a bit older and go oh you
know I really want monogamy there what
she's scared of is her dude getting a 21
year old that's what she's [ __ ]
scared of she may not know it she may
not say it but basically that's what the
truth is